انشغال الجيش تسبب في مشكله اخرى وهي
انعدام الامن وانتشار الفوضى منظمه اي اس
اي ار الالمانيه وكاله الاغاثه الالمانيه
علقتها عمليات الانقاذ في تركيا بسبب
مخاوف على امن فرقهم التي تعمل في اقليميه
مدير عمليات منظمه الاغاثه الالمانيه تحدث
عن صراع بين جماعات مختلفه بسبب ازمه غذاء
وماء مما جعل الحزن يتحول الى غضب ترجمته
اصوات اطلاق النار الفريق النمساوي
العسكري بدوره اوقف جهود الانقاذ والمبرر
كان اولويه سلامه فريقه الامن اذا ثغره او
بالاحرى فجوه اعترف ايضا اردوغان بوجودها
واطلقت تهديدات
للاسف بعض الاشخاص اقتحموا الاسواق او
المحلات التجاريه بهدف نهب السلع والمواد
الغذائيه الدوله اتخذت خطوات حازمه مع
هؤلاء وسنعاقبهم بشده الدوله ومؤسساتها
حاضره وتقدم كل المساعدات لكن الى غايه
اللحظه لم نتمكن من ايصال المساعدات الى
بعض المناطق اعترف ان الوضع صعب لكن
الدوله تواصل العمل من اجل بلوغ كل
المناطق المتضرره